so today we're going to talk about
berberine okay
berberine is the next
turmeric okay it is actually incredible
it's been thoroughly studied it's a lot
of people know about it but they don't
know
all the different things it can do some
hardcore research on a lot of things
especially the cardiovascular system
it's a very powerful antiarrhythmic
natural compound now berberine is a
phytonutrient
in certain plants okay so it's not
necessarily a name
of a plant and because the mechanism of
arrhythmias
involve calcium berberine can decrease
the intracellular calcium
which is one actual cause of
the heart going out of rhythm because
calcium is an electrolyte if there's too
much calcium in the cell becomes toxic
and it affects the
the electrical system in the heart it
can also decrease
blood pressure it can increase the
performance of the actual heart muscle
itself
it decreases the risk of heart attacks
protects against ischemia and heart
muscle this is a lack of oxygen
if there's some type of obstruction
because there's a clogged artery that's
causing
a lack of blood flow to the heart muscle
this can
help it also it can alter potassium
channels
now potassium is a mineral that protects
excessive amounts of calcium going into
the cell
and this is why certain arrhythmias are
actually caused by low potassium
because if you don't have enough
potassium you can't protect against the
excess amount of calcium that builds up
inside the cells
berberine can help as an anticoagulant
so that can help reduce clotting number
two and this is a well-known benefit
can decrease infectious diarrhea so if
you have an infection that's causing
diarrhea
i would start taking berberine all right
number three
it can act as a natural antibiotic okay
which actually
explains number two it's also an immune
stimulant it can help
boost your immune system number five
anti-tumor
anti-cancer big time in fact there's
just a lot of studies going on
using this berberine on tumors and
cancer
which you know you don't hear about
unless you actually dig in to find this
this data number six and this is
actually a very important
benefit it has anti-diabetic properties
it can
potentially decrease your blood sugars
it can help with insulin resistance
making insulin and glucose more
sensitive
so your blood sugars are going to be
much better
there's been some reports that this will
work just as good if not better
than metformin realize i'm not making
any claims check with your doctor before
consuming this but you may just want to
read the research yourself
all right number seven it can help
decrease the effects of
caffeine caffeine can trigger
arrhythmias
well berberine decreases the effect of
caffeine
all right number eight it's
anti-inflammatory
it's very very effective for anything
that has itis
bursitis tendinitis arthritis
and it's antiviral other than that
it probably doesn't work for anything
else and i'm being very very sarcastic
this is the next turmeric i think it's a
very powerful phytonutrient that i think
more people need to know about
all right thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering in keto
absolutely not karen and it's an immune
system builder
absolutely you have to check this out i
think you should hurry up
watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be
keto but is it simple it's super simple
we hope you enjoy making it as much as
we are enjoying eating it